by now everyone's heard that rihanna and
NBA player dwight howard both tweeted
free palestine and then deleted the
tweets but who really cares what
celebrities think about international
news anyway well here's one reason to
care image is everything an israel like
many countries invests a lot in its
public image the government has even
been buying and promoting tweets during
its current military offensive in gaza
that's because israel doesn't want to be
viewed negatively in light of its
ongoing occupation of Palestinian land
and so when celebrities bring attention
to Palestinian hardships it undermines
Israel's public image and sometimes
unintentionally boosts movements like
BDS BD what that's BDS which stands for
boycott divest and sanction of Israel
that is it's a campaign modeled after a
similar movement that successfully
helped end apartheid in South Africa its
supporters now hope the movement will
pressure Israel to comply with
international law and respect
Palestinian rights one of the movements
goals is a cultural boycott of Israel by
artists filmmakers and even athletes who
are urged not to visit or perform there
and so far it's seen results with
several artists cancelling their
concerts in Israel that includes Elvis
Costello Snoop Dogg and Carlos Santana
for their part Israelis say they're
unfairly targeted and that the movement
ignores other human rights abusers
obviously a divisive issue and
celebrities who stumble into it tweeting
support for Palestine often end up
retracting their statement and then
apologizing and these days even
celebrities who are unwavering in their
support of Israel also have to deal with
fallout despite it all a number of famed
voices like Pink Floyd's Roger Waters
Talib Kweli
waka flocka DJ Khaled Eddie Vedder and
Anthony Bourdain have expressed sympathy
for Palestine during this most recent
violence but what do you think does a
celebrity tweeting hashtag free
Palestine even make a difference tell us
in the comments below and tweet us at
aj+
[Music]